vous êtes un peu d'empathie c'est vrai
tu en sais quel théâtre l'empathie non
ça c'est contrarié non là c'est trop
crispé je fais un sourire encourageant
désolé pas trop bien comment gérer ça
hasselhoff avec sa première fois que ça
m'arrive mais moi aussi c'est la
première fois que je perds memory hockey
partout
alors soyons administratif alors la
bonne nouvelle un nom alors voilà en
tant que peuvent vous avez le droit à
une pension de réversion il faut un acte
de décès et un certificat d'hérédité
sinon moi je ne peux rien débloqué pour
les documents je peux vous aider à les
réunir pour que j'ai dit ça je veux pas
faire ça je dois juste que ce moment se
termine enfin je dis ça se trouve
peut-être pas besoin d aide si je veux
bien
et merde moi je dis ça parce que moi
j'ai besoin je dois appeler l'urssaf
l'ircantec la la caisse de retraite les
responsabilités de l'employeur
voilà le montant du capital décès s'est
revalorisée tous les ans c'est dommage
il au ciel
quinze jours passés en tête au long
cours je suis nul à lesquin peu d'affect
xavier sur la couronne de fleurs merci
elle était bien donc pas vraiment fait
attention on trouvait que le nom de la
société stern
patrice tout donc on a rajouté à notre
collègue quand ça tombe sur moi je le
connaissais même pas ce type ok alors
oui c'est ma collaboratrice délégué qui
a réuni toutes ces affaires oui alors
dont le clavier ergonomique je peux pas
vous laisser par contre parce que ça
partir la société je suis absolument
désolé c'est eux
ça c'est la faute d'alice d'attaquer la
voilà à l'iss un kia qui a vérifié
je suis navré je vais je vais faire le
tri alors ticket restaurant ticket resto
on est le combien je vous la laisse tous
[Musique]
mourir au bureau c'est sordide
mais je vais mourir dans un truc tu es
du panache sépare deltaplane ou foudroyé
tient très bien la foudroyé en
deltaplane prends je veux pas mourir je
veux pas mourir bien ça cette saison
marque fétiche la bande était fred vous
étiez proche ah oui c'était quelqu'un
votre mari voilà c'est bien ça écrit sa
légende rend la heureuse beaucoup de
qualités une ride arrivait tous les
matins au bureau ayant levé son manteau
il a allumé son ordinateur et hop
mais les mails et puis la rue c'était le
rayon de soleil de laitages tellement
drôle chaque jacques jacques abry alors
il a encore fait une blague l'autre jour
là je la leur foi super drôle super
drôle on a tellement ri vous me racontez
non mais c'était une sur le régime
fiscal de la boîte c'était très très
drôle très drôle mais c'était du monde
deux juristes il était pas très drôle
ah bon c'est bizarre ça serait chez
passer ma vie avec quelqu'un que je
connais pas vraiment il passa passa je
suis rabattu mais qui sait ça abc vous
ça à la c'est bien bien vous 1-1
regarder ah ça c'est vous la qui d'autre
qui d'autre qui d'autre est là quelqu'un
d'objets qui d'autre dans ses excès
c'est vous sur la photo personne d'autre
ah non non non non c'est une expression
non je veux dire ccc vous aussi sur la
photo cibc des papes et bien d'autres
dimensions à l'aide
non je vous assure que non mais c'est
quoi c'est de la solidarité masculine
solidarité mais ce que qua non il est
apte à toute réunion entre collègues
vous faites des idées vraiment désolé je
vais rentrer tard ce soir j'ai tu as
connu un salon où le mauvais timing
c'est une merde non là je vous êtes un
fan en sortir car notre cave s'est hissé
sa petite s'accroît de ses ailes
mais non fiable ce petit pas du tout à
ses services à laisser ma peau je le
connais je le connais pas je le connais
pas votre mari voilà je ne connais pas
je sais juste que c'est le mec qui est
mort sur la photocopieuse la
photocopieuse
non mais c'est tout le même
[Musique]